so remember a few bat a few months back
when joe rogan got covered and the
media's lying d-bags claimed he took
horse pills
sorry did i say lying d-bags i mean
stupid lying d-bags can you believe like
joe rogan yeah he's eating eating
dewormers he says he is taking several
medications including a drug meant for
deworming livestock in case you missed
it rogan said the word ivormectin yes
that's the deworming medicine made to
kill parasites and farm animals when you
have a horse deworming medication that's
discouraged by the government that
actually causes some people in this
crazed environment we're in to actually
want to try it that's the upside down
where we're in with figures like joe
rogan
sorry
horse pills more like horse
of course ivormectum's been approved for
human use for decades while these dopes
od'd on whatever turns you into a
horse's ass
remember these are the people who get
everything wrong they can diagnose what
rogan puts in his mouth but missed
everything coming out of chris cuomo's
it's also ironic that stelter would be
critical of anyone about covid given
he's a walking risk factor for every
medical condition on earth he's a petri
dish wearing extra large sweatpants
he is to health problems what horse dung
is to flies
he needs to mask up to limit his
exposure to cinnabons
damn i mean whose advice would you
rather take rogan who's built like a
brick wall or stelter who's built like
an unripe avocado
so as usual their ridicule was based on
a lie one they never rescinded so rogan
called out cnn's very own medical expert
do you think that's a problem that your
news network is not lies
well i don't i don't dude what did they
say they lied what did they say i was
taking a horse dewormer does it bother
you that the news network you worked for
out and out lied was outright lied about
me taking horse dewormer they they
shouldn't have said that why did they do
that i don't know
being the medical expert at cnn is a lot
like being the executive chef at a
prison
it's a nice title but you're not going
to put it on your tinder profile
of course months later joe joined
spotify and those coveted lies came back
and in a last-ditch effort to stay
relevant musical artist neil young and
joni mitchell threatened to boycott
demanding spotify dump rogan if there
were any grouchier they'd live in a
garbage can
although that might be where joni
mitchell's lived since the 1970s
but it's weird how the usual defenders
of artistic freedom decided to become
corporate sensors they went from selling
out arenas to just selling out but if
you aren't familiar with neil young or
joni mitchell here's a clip of their
classics
[Music]
don't it always seem to go
don't know what you got to do
you know they're both from canada by the
way there must be something in the water
up there and judging by their voices
it's razor blades
spotify shut down the whiny old farts so
the singers removed their catalog from
spotify how did music fans react
[Applause]
of course during all this how did we
cover it roll it clyde
now the rogan story has gotten
widespread media coverage far more
coverage than how small the risk covet
poses for young people and you got
places like cnn jealous that rogan often
has more influence than they do piling
on they don't like his dangerous ideas
about free speech exercising god forbid
cracking jokes there's likely no person
on earth who's doing more to dismantle
idea segregation than him the roster of
his guests are more diverse than the
olympic opening ceremonies and they're
allowed to speak endlessly about
whatever so the listener can decide it's
the antidote to cable tv where shows
rely on the same people who say the same
things over and over again and no wonder
cnn hates rogan he's widening the
universe as they shrink it
i believe i am the true hero
i heard rogan has a bronze bust of me
right next to the
bong here he is just tuesday on his
podcast where he claims fox and others
had his back
who would have thought that
if you look back on the early days what
we used to think of as conservative
versus liberal liberal was pro-free
speech
people were open-minded
non-violent you know and people were
open to other people's ideas
and the right was like suppressive
you know nanny state you know
condemn certain language condemn certain
behaviors that's not the case today yeah
today the left has gone so
far left
that sounds really familiar
keep going joe rowe
so radical that the right are the ones
that are celebrating comedians and
celebrating chappelle yeah they had my
back through all the crazy that happened
with me it was fox news that had my back
so this is the point i've been making
since forever or at least since cat
turned 40.
that what you're seeing is the big flip
whereas the left retreats into a whoa
cocoon of intolerance the only real
defenders of artistic freedom has to be
us
which is hard it's like i don't already
have enough to do teaching glassblowing
to marginalized communities
but it was a promise we made years ago
that we righties must share the risk
with liberals who are under attack even
if they hate us if we defend those who
may not care for us whether it's rogan
or mar or chappelle they may at some
point see the value in the mission
because sharing risk is all we have in
the battle for our freedoms it's also
the right thing to do and it's something
we know firsthand here having endured
the same treatment for decades no one
knows better than us boycotts cancer
culture i've been there the insults the
name calling the threats of violence and
that's just what i get from geraldo
so we will happily defend others even if
they may still stubbornly claim to be
liberals and they may hate us doesn't
matter they need us more than we need
them because you're going to see the
left split even further into warring
factions in which only one side is
really warring and the other side is
simply leaving it's like a spouse
divorcing a super crazy partner
meanwhile as the left makes
humorlessness hysterical the right loses
its scolds and replaces them with
fun-loving sickos we go from jerry
falwell to this
which
which one would you rather have your
kids grow up like
all right bad example
and not because one's dead and the other
one's dead inside
we are now the party of freedom and the
party of speech in fact we are just the
party
because over there on the other side
it's no party at all fun is eroding
faster than joe biden's frontal lobes
because we know when you throw away free
speech other freedoms follow and so does
the fun people so does the fun
by offering your hand to the people
being attacked they often come around
you can still disagree on many things
but there's one thing you can never
abandon and that's your right to speak
and your ability to share it so you're
welcome joe happy to help we'll pat
ourselves on the back for having yours
let's welcome
a nice yes
she's so evil
dante had a circle of hell made just for
her fox news at night anchor evil
shannon
he's the only cash not accepted by
hunter biden former white house national
security council aide and
author of the new children's book the
plot against the king
kaspatel
[Applause]
she's like a kite colorful bright and
hanging on by a thread
fox news contributor cat tip
and
when he builds a sand castle at the
beach it's put on the market my massive
sidekick in the nwa world television
champion tyrus
shannon how are you excellent great to
have you on the show as always a
pleasure
are you happy to be here pleasure is
mine uh it should be yeah so would you
agree that i played the main part in
bringing justice to joe rogan am i the
real hero here um if you say so yes
you are um i want to see you guys do a
push-up contest then i will be able to
make a determination isn't it
interesting how fox i mean fox is
anti-cancer culture probably because
we know people screw up and we allow for
second chances yeah and that's kind of
the antidote for everything right yeah
and we all need that and what
interesting conversations another thing
on any of our shows that you watch
you're going to hear from multiple sides
it's not fun to just get beat over the
head with one side and have no
exploration of ideas or anything else
bill maher is very good at this too i
mean you had him up somebody that is i
would say the old school version of a
liberal where you have an open mind free
speech let's debate ideas that kind of
thing um when you close it down it just
gets uninteresting and i think joe knows
we've got his back you specifically give
you credit well you know um i g i have
everybody's back
and sometimes front yes that is true
she's learning evil shannon breem
cash good to see you congratulations on
the children's book i brought you a copy
but shannon gets up i think you're
i think you're stretching it calling
that a book though
it's over 20 pages
which is which is your limit that's not
even the length of my monologues
it's got colorful pictures in it oh
did you do the artwork yeah no you did
that's it
this is a scam
russian game for kids is not a scam
tell the truth you are crazy the best
seller and google suppressed it today oh
really they actually crushed the entire
ad campaign no way that's how you become
even a bigger bestseller that's good
that'll help you that's they call that
the streisand effect
i'll take crew they're laughing but
that's what they call it i didn't name
it
anyway cash isn't it interesting this
whole flip like now it's the right
because i'm old enough to remember that
the right word was like the dean wermer
they were the people that hated speech
and hated comedy it's completely flipped
and now the left is the new moral
majority do you find that strange
comforting weird will you write a
children's book about it it's my sequel
and i'm going to put gandalf the greg in
my neck
you're with the same height i think it's
what happens in government that's
probably the only thing i could speak to
since i spent my life in it now i'm
trying to make money but you're not
helping yes um
but basically what happens is government
goes oh we're gonna do an over
correction you know crime is too high so
let's just bury everybody right and
everybody's getting sick so let's
inoculate everybody and the left is
doing the exact same thing with the
media and now they don't really have my
former boss to sort of knock over the
head so they've lost that bludgeoning
pin and now they're just basically like
well we have to keep going we can't stop
and that's why you got you know old
school guys like bill maher are gone and
you have joe rogan my only problem with
joe rogan is he put on the fake cnn
indian doctor and he could have had this
bollywood indian doctor
and so i kind of probably will decline
his offer when he offers oh well i had
no idea when you do your push-up card it
is true though it's like since trump
kind of left this trump-sized hole
right or trump-shaped hole a little call
back to nirvana but anyway um
that they tried to fill with rogan and
then they tried to fill with tucker and
now they i think believe that they're
trying to fill it with elon musk they
keep like putting they keep thinking how
are they going to do this you know tyler
so it's interesting you know what's
interesting about this kind of like
conflict between a liberal like uh joe
rogan and the left
is that they can't pin him down
so that's why it's like he because if
you have to adhere to every single
point that they believe or you're out of
the club so if they can't pin you down
like you and i don't agree on like
a lot of things right yeah well i mean
you don't agree on my plans for tonight
no example that's why i'm not
participating um i'm gonna surprise you
though yeah it's impossible i never give
them address of where i'm staying um
it's not even that they
they always swing up
because they can't lose yeah you attack
an institution like joe robin you attack
an institution like president trump
what's the worst thing that can happen
you you get his attention and when you
get his attention what happens
you get a lot of attention and you make
money
and it's the easiest way to make money
is to punch at somebody else's success
that's the whole point of cancel culture
it's people who can't go after someone
who is they find the smallest thing and
instead of they don't take him to court
they they don't try to sue him saying
that he defamed them or hurt their
feelings because they'd be laughed out
of court so they go to the social mob
like twitter or whatever where there's
no courts no laws no reasoning and you
can cancel somebody and just say bring
up something they did like you take
kevin hart for example something he did
apologize for and never did again they
wanted him to re-apologize for and then
when he didn't they got what they wanted
they well they yeah they they ruined the
economy not that the academy always
needed much more help to be ruined but
they took a great comedian from it why
because they couldn't be there so that's
what they're doing so going after musk
going after president trump anybody
who's done it or made it is a target so
congratulations king of knight they're
going to come after you next because
you're there and kat and i will remember
all the kind words you said about us
when you need us supporting you and
getting your back
what can they say about me that i
haven't already said about myself that's
extremely disgusting it depends what
time of the day they call us
but you know what it's kind of
interesting though we talked about this
whole thing about sharing the risk
that's the whole point of this it should
be above and i think as left and right
fall apart that's all that's going to be
left is the it's going to be sane
versus insane people
yeah especially because the standards
that you know they expect people to
stick to nobody can adhere to that
especially because we also have people
you bring up kevin hart but you have
people who've gotten canceled over
things they tweeted like 10 years before
when they were teenagers
uh there was that woman that's supposed
to be the editor of vogue and then she
had some insensitive tweets about asians
that she had already apologized for but
then was asked to re-apologize for and
then she was you know never able to
start that job even though we found out
one of the woman who was women who was
leading the charge to cancel her she had
old tweets where she was using the
n-word nobody everybody makes a mistake
at some point and it's really unfair to
or it's actually just stupid to say that
a single comment uh is a snapshot
that uh can encapsulate an entire person
because we're all a lot more complex
than that aren't we though yeah some of
us we're all like precious snowflakes
what well i mean i mean
they don't all have to be white i mean
but they're just yeah i know he and i
are not white yeah right yeah
it was meant like the uniqueness of a
snowflake okay fine yeah what does a
creepy snowflake look like
that's what he's saying
shut up
i'm going to the break now hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else